oh hi oh yeah didn't he come in so
welcome to my office this is my little
corner of the euro claim project office
Hannah I'll give you a really quick
desktop now okay so here's my work but
it's important because it's a book I
like books and it's got to work in
that's my laptop which has got two
scripts with crash course videos and
that's my Japanese peace lily always
important to keep that around because it
keeps the air oxygenated that's water
he'll hydrate
that's Jeff Alice's textbook that's a
series of papers that I'm reading at the
moment that's an award that I got for
the Tokyo scientists car game with
expression FM and Hannah over here we've
got a whole bunch of random things
including some old document I wrote some
papers that's a saxophone some shoes for
the office oh and that's my computer
where I'm currently running stuff and
it's showing Jupiter at the moment and
these pink things are papers that I
still need to read and add to my papers
document and it's currently nine minutes
to midnight on today which is Wednesday
just going to date the vlog right there
I have been here during the day and
doing doing PhD stuff and then I was
singing in ecstasy drool and I've come
back here to film my crash course stuff
so I just did the second batch of crash
course videos which is free videos I
just like to say if you are not aware I
am doing a crash course now it's very
physics I'm really quite pleased with
other videos that come out the first
ones weren't in focus unfortunately but
thank you Sally for recommending that I
get this thing which is a remote shutter
so I can focus on me one line not right
by the camera because I was want to
doing any by myself it's a bit difficult
hashtag youtuber problems but the rubber
is yeah it's really late I just finished
recording and I thought you know what I
need sleep no no not sleepy other thing
I need to make a vlog because it's been
a little while since I've done
and I said that I try to do them more
frequently so yeah for me for actually
trying to you know stick to my word
oh but game that's the crash course
stuff I'm really pleased that's this
I've want to do educational content for
awhile if you haven't watched them then
what are you doing go and watch those
videos there I'm really proud of how
they come out I really hope the people
are enjoying them some people have been
really enjoying them and thank you to
everyone in the comments I just like to
say that if you would like more that
kind of content what you've got to do is
like it share it get more people to view
it because basically there are a lot of
effort they are an awful lot of work to
write to film to produce they're a lot
more intense than doing a vlog like this
so if you want more of it you've got to
show me that you really want it so show
it to your friends show it to people in
your school like it whatever and the
other way that you can show support for
it is I now have a Conners page Conners
is a website which you've heard of
before in my youtube space blog when I
met Federico who is the founder of
Conners and it's an educational website
where basically it gives you additional
frameworks to educational series so it
allows you to keep track of how far
through you are I also allows you to
financially support creators so if you
want you don't have to it's a free
service but if you want you can make
donations to me like it's a patreon page
like you can do that on a monthly basis
or run like a one-off the nation thing I
realized that most people watch my
videos are students and so they have
very little money so don't worry if you
if you have no money then don't give me
what little you have because frankly I'm
not worth it but if you would like more
of that kind of content more the crash
course stuff then that's another very
clear message for me if you donate to
the cause page then that basically
telling me hey if you do this kind of
content maybe when you graduate you
could do this full-time which is
something I am thinking of doing doing
video work full-time and doing
educational video work full-time so
that's that's how you can support me on
that front anyway where are my manners
how are you anyway I'm doing all right
life's been really busy at the moment I
am doing the crash course stuff I am
also in the process of writing and
producing videos about the climate
change talks are happening in Paris I'm
also doing a lot of singing as I said
earlier I've just come back from Exeter
Cathedral and we've got a lot of
remembrance services on if you're in the
x---two area
come hear me singing the University
Chapel Choir and in addition to that PhD
is happening so the update on PhD is
that basically I wrote a document this
document which is a review of my work
essentially like it's it's going for a
derivation of this equation that I've
derived for how mass flows in and out
the polar stratosphere and testing it
basically like doing forecast testing
and I had a meeting today with my
supervisor my mathematical supervisor
who basically tore apart the main
dynamical equation which I'm actually
surprisingly okay with because I now
feel like I feel like it wasn't legit to
begin with I I didn't really trust what
I'd done it felt very primitive and so
now I'm going through this textbook
which is must fear ik and oceanic fluid
dynamics by Jeff Alice who is here at
Exeter and it's literally the book on
planetary fluid mechanics so I'm
spending a lot of time Jeff and I spend
a lot of time together and I'm now what
you caught me doing was making notes
from that textbook and then we're going
to be trying again using a different set
of assumptions I think a particular
we're gonna be going down a G cause I
geostrophic route and then in addition
to that I'm also going for him writing
up a whole bunch of different papers
we've got down with control we've got
breaking planetary ways we've got the
importance of surface pressure changes
in the response the atmosphere is
certainly symmetric thermal and
mechanical forcing classic and we've got
the downward influence of sudden
stratospheric warming stress effect
sudden warnings even constantly so
what's going on basically um yeah I'm
really tired I mentioned that in
addition to whining about my PhD though
I have a particular thing I want to talk
about in this blog and that is why
Thomas Frank is awesome so in case you
haven't guessed a physicist who also
makes YouTube videos is really into Star
Wars like absolutely love Star Wars it
was the film that got me into cinema
really my mom brought home the special
edition box set in 1997 and I was like
hooked so I am of course going to go and
see the force awakens when it comes out
in December the problem is I'm in
America when the force awakens comes out
and I'm there for a conference in San
Francisco
which yes if you did miss the previous
vlog I'm going to be vlogging the whole
experience cuz it's going to be amazing
but I'm going to be over there when the
force awakens comes out so I spent
pretty much a whole day trying to buy
American cinema tickets and Americans I
hope you realized that it's basically
impossible for a non-american or rather
someone who's not in America it's
basically impossible for a non-american
to buy American cinema tickets as I
found out there's a consortium of me and
a few friends who were all going to this
conference
robbing nerds but what we were going to
a scientific conference of course with
big nerds and we all want to see Star
Wars so I was tasked with trying to buy
these tickets for everyone and I found
it was basically impossible for
traditional routes you needed an
American credit card but my friend had a
suggestion what if we buy a gift card
from Amazon then we use that gift card
on the store site and we don't need to
give her credit card details and we just
pay by the credit buy the gift card boom
amazing idea didn't work David did it
because it turned out that we couldn't
use that gift card online we slightly
missed the small print kind of a kind of
mutual thought there in fact and I had
no option I I had run out of ideas so I
sent a message to the hero of the story
Thomas Frank as like a hologram it was
like it was like the ED the r2d2
hologram of Princess Leia I was like oh
my god Tom you're my only hope
can you please buy me some of our
tickets had a had a Google hell with the
man absolutely lovely if you if you saw
our livestream you'll know that he's
amazing
can you tell I'm just defusing with
praise and gratitude but the fact of
actually now get to go see Star Wars in
3d in an IMAX
I can't wait when it's late
so Tom bought cinema tickets for me and
a bunch of friends I pay them back and
I'm now going to be able to go see Star
Wars at midnight when it comes out in 3d
and IMAX and I'm incredibly excited and
to be honest it's probably going to form
a fair part of the aju vlogs so you know
I just I was sorry
right I'm now going to leave you because
it is now Thursday and I haven't slept
and I need sleep because PhD I don't do
PhD unless I sleep I could sleep here
but now I'm going to go home and if
you're not watching this crash course
videos then please go back and watch
them because I'm really proud of them
and if you are watching them then you're
awesome and I look forward to seeing you
in the next crash course video I don't
know when I next gonna vlog because I I
just don't know about anything anymore
really so yeah thanks for watching like
onions like ogres the atmosphere is made
of many layers and these are layers
which humans have to find but have a
physical normal arbitrary basic sort of
as a positive thing like everyone loves
birthday cake but I could have talked
about something a bit more negative I
could have talked about the fact that
you are partly made of late-night
comfort food eating sessions where you
try and drown your bad feelings in cars